this is like the third or fourth james
bond song in a row that's won the oscar
and they're all good
they deserve it um how did you approach
writing this song knowing that so many
of them had done so well
um scared very intimidated um but we
we've looked up to the the music in the
bond franchise for pretty much like as
long as i can remember um as like
i don't know it's so weird there was
there was there was um
no uh confusion at all about bond and
the music it has been such a big part of
our lives for so long that the fact that
we are involved at all was
unbelievable um and the approach was
very
very exhilarating and like peak life and
also scary
and we just had so much pressure put on
ourselves like we put it on ourselves we
were so we just wanted it to be perfect
and represent daniel craig's last film
and all of his films and how much you
know he put into it and
it just was the most amazing experience
ever
i wanna i i wanna just say two things
one is phineas
just a huge fan thank you you're just
terrific and billy you are too but we've
seen you sort of grow phineas is older
than you we've seen you sort of grow up
since your first album came out yeah and
when you first came out you were sort of
like an emo kind of sad looking teenager
and now you're like laughing and having
a good time and you look very happy and
it's so nice to see
do you feel that you've had a change in
your career as the last couple of years
have gone along i mean i went from um 14
to 20. uh-huh so that'll do it you know
do you feel a lot better now yeah sure i
mean yeah i was i was a i was also you
know
a very young teenager very you know you
you know teenagers
um but i
i don't know it's just growth and like
aging i think um but yeah i'm super
happy i feel so
like i think that i'm i'm just coming
into my um
being aware of what is good and
around me you know i think that when i'm
that young like when you're that young
it's like hard to understand how big of
a deal things are around you and how
um important things are and you know you
meet a kid like i i'll meet people that
are younger than me and be like
wow they have they have no idea how cool
this is and it's just like they're kids
i just was a kid and i don't i didn't
know and i'm so so thrilled that that
growing up has has uh taught me to just
be like
more aware of the the greatness around
me
yeah all right
133 followed by 130.
hi he's with uh from buzzfeed here huge
huge huge huge oh where are you
hi sorry huge fans thank you you both um
again you know we it was brought up that
you know this is i believe the third
bond song to win an oscar and i'm just
curious if you talked with sam smith or
adele or any of the previous writers um
on songs before you guys tackled no time
to die great question i did yeah i
talked to jimmy napes and sam both um
when we were hoping that we'd be
given the opportunity to write a james
bond theme and i just asked what the
process was like because it was again it
was like a
such a ambition of ours so it was it was
really just like picking their brains
about it and um it was really
interesting to um
to hear their take on it and they were
very encouraging and and gave really
good advice which was basically just to
to make a song we're really proud of
hello
all right 130 followed by our remote
press room
hey this is nadja from forbes way over
here congrats on the win i would love to
know what was the biggest challenge
putting together this song and also
working together as siblings
um
i think the biggest challenge was um
like making sure that it felt to us
uh
what's the word
authentic but also
what's the word pain like tribute not
even tribute what's the word i'm
thinking appropriate i mean i'll go
appropriate it was really important to
us that it felt like a billy isler song
and a james bond song at the same time
and not one or the other yeah it was it
was so so important to have it
pay you know like
all of the respects needed for all of
the bond films in the past and not take
anything away from that and i was really
really like
on that i really didn't want to
disrespect the franchise in any way i
wanted to make everybody happy and and
it's you know easier to said than done
but it was a
challenge and we you know we worked hard
to like maintain that not to take away
from the french and you don't want to
feel like a cover you want to feel like
your song that you have ownership over
yeah yeah
thank you and we'll take one last
question from our remote press room from
the uk press association
it'll be a slight delay okay
hi guys it's uh mike mike from the uh uk
press association here um
congratulations obviously uh and like
everyone else has said massive fan um
yeah i was just wondering as obviously
the first u.s artist to win
uh this award for a bond song how does
it feel to kind of be joining i guess
the british family in a way um you know
part of the other incredible artists
that have done the same and billy i know
you um previously said that you were
kind of worried that um daniel wouldn't
like the song so do you think you've you
think you've made him proud with it now
i hope so jeez um but yeah no that's
that's a really good question nobody's
really pointed that out before um
yeah i think that was another thing i
again like i really wanted to
like
you know pay my respects to every aspect
of bond and it's you know i'm from the
us i'm american and i i didn't want to
like take away from anything and um it's
it's so incredible to be
in
you know the list of people that have
created bond songs and i don't know it's
it's it's so
so insane and i i don't know how to
really process it and uh
um what was the second thing
what did you say
what was the second thing you said i
just if you'd uh daniel
yeah
um he's the sweetest man alive and i
i just really wanted him to love it i
wanted him to feel like it represented
his years and his last film and i wanted
him to be happy kind of most of all he's
james bond come on
so yeah
thank you so much